Ali is with us in Houston Texas hi Ali
how are you hi Dave thank you so much
for taking my call sir I'm doing great
how are you better than I deserve
how can I help today awesome okay so my
wife and I we own a business
we're completely debt-free I paid the
business off three years into purchasing
it I've got quite a bit of liquid cash
don't know what to do with it you know
the market kind of makes me nervous I
don't know if it should be invested in
the market or if I should go towards
real estate how old are you 32 years old
what kind of business I own a drugstore
or pharmacy cool and how much extra cash
we we've managed to have some good years
we ended up saving about six and a half
to two to about seven million dollars in
cash it's all just sitting in cash all
sitting in cash whoo Wow yep for you
good for you yeah you've got to get this
invested because you're making 1% on it
versus if you made 10% on it and 10% on
that's like this is like a $600,000 a
year swing yeah so sitting there in cash
is it's mathematically lazy right that
money's not working very hard it's not
doing it's not lifting as much as it
should be lifting and so I'm definitely
getting that invested somewhere else so
let me ask you this though before I do
that the you're obviously very very good
at running your business congratulations
thank you won't you buy some more
drugstores you know what we won when we
got in we had some we had some good
years where we're not doing nearly
as well as we used to do to insurance
changes and so on and so forth
okay so you don't think if you took a
million dollars of this six million and
open another store that you'd get a good
rate of return on it I don't think so I
mean we'd probably be looking at about
ten percent of a group ten percent of
about gross sales so you know which we'd
probably be ended up you know making a
hundred and fifty grand extra mm-hm
okay and what would it cost to open that
store if if if we were to open one up
you know we'd probably be looking at
about six between six and seven hundred
thousand okay well let's take a hundred
fifty thousand dollar rate of return ROI
okay return on investment on six hundred
thousand yeah that's a twenty five
percent rate of return that's why I
asked the question small businesses are
a higher hassle factor but they
generally give a much better rate of
return than real estate or the stock
market and you're obviously very good at
it it's not as it's not as sweet as it
used to be but maybe you can find you're
gonna pay cash for it anyway whatever
you do so I'm thinking I'm gonna I'm not
gonna put put the whole six million on
that and you may not want the hassle you
may not want the stress of running more
stores you know but if I were in your
shoes just from a product mix standpoint
and an investment mix standpoint I'm
probably taking a million two and
opening two more stores if you can
handle the hassle factor of it and the
stress of it if you can put in six
hundred and make 150 out of your net
profit after all the smoke clears that's
a good rate of return and that's someone
else you know how are you a good manager
put them in there you know that kind of
stuff let somebody else take some of
that off of you you don't have to do
everything hands-on like you used to do
but I might expend that part of my
portfolio because that again I answer
questions here like what would I do and
I can tell you the best rate of return I
get is Ramsey solutions putting money
into a new product here makes me more
money than putting more money into a
piece of real estate does and I love
real estate so that's why I answered the
question that way you don't have to do
that
just an idea so what I would do if I
were in your shoes other than that if
you don't want to do that or even if you
do want to do that I'm gonna put the
larger portion of the six million into
some real estate that makes an income
that I pay cash for would you would you
recommend like a apartment building or
like just individual residential homes
well I mean we're talking about probably
four million dollars here yeah and so
individual homes are probably going to
be a high hassle factor because that's
going to be a bunch of them yeah so I
probably would look more towards a
commercial piece of property with four
million dollars a L placed good
neighborhood small office building a
well placed good neighborhood a small
strip Center something along those lines
I've got two or three of each of those
that do very very well and there's just
one or two tenants involved for four
million dollars instead of twenty-two
tenants and so that's kind of a way to
look at it and then I'd probably take
about you know if I took the six million
I'd probably say I'm going to put a
million million and a half and some more
drug stores or I'm going to put about
four million into some real estate I'm
gonna put a million me and a half into
the stock market and then you're
thinking in the stock market not what's
it gonna do tomorrow because I don't
know what it's gonna do tomorrow 2018
sucked 2019 2019 however was a 19
percent rate of return which means you
would have made a million dollars on
your six hundred thousand that's what
you missed out in 19 or in is 17 I'm
sorry in 2017 there's a 19 percent rate
of return that's you know 20 percent on
6 million bucks and million - right gee
that's that's a killer when you look at
that that's what that's what I'm being
afraid the stock market cost you now
last year and you make a dime so you
know about broke even basically so I
don't know what 19 is gonna bring but
you don't buy the stock market you don't
buy real estate for short term
investments you buy them for 5 10 20 30
years out and you ride them all the way
out and that's what you watch so that's
how I would break it down if I were in
your shoes and I think that'll turn your
6 million in a 20 million in
four and a half or five years